hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the chest 24 Bandra
blitz session it's the Iranian Hulk as
our chassis story Nolan pure can called
him on Twitter
Parham mokuba again spanish grandmaster
daniel alsina and it's a really really
instructive game on how to play against
the knight or especially a special when
you're you're really low on time as this
is a three minute blitz game but as
you'll see it's it's a game worthy of a
classical game so really impressive
stuff I do hope you enjoy it and sorry
about no video yesterday I really
couldn't manage the time as I it was the
last day at the tournament that was
playing Indian I did well out of three
possible points I did two out of three
on the last day and I will show you one
of the games about later today I just
wanted to show you this one it is I just
saw it on Twitter and also for those of
you who are still interested in joining
our elite chess team battle the first
link in the description below is where
you can join our team and help us fight
this battle and the second link is the
tournament is already created so on the
second link if you joined our team you
can join the tournament which will
happen on January 9th so that's it and
for those of you who still are not a
part of the subscribers video do do
become a part of the subscribers video
as we will start editing it maybe in a
week or so so you still have time to
send us some photos or videos if you
don't know what it is you know
explanation of that will also be in the
description below so do check it out now
on to the game part of mokuba versus
daniel Alcina mokuba opens with E 4 we
have C 5 the Sicilian defense night of 3
D 6 and D for we have C captures night
captures Knight to f6 with Knight to c3
and a6 the night of defenses on the
board and as mokuba said in his
adventure blade session he is not a
knight or specialist so he doesn't
really know all the intricacies of the
line that he goes for he goes for Bishop
to g5 the so called I don't know if it
is the browser but Bishop to g5 often is
referred to as the director rouser amber
okay Bishop g5 we have e 6 quinta e to
the shrubbery 7
just standard stuff mock Zulu castles
and the Queen to c7 we have f4 so again
all standard stuff and this has all been
played in classical chess with Knight B
to d7 G for continuing the expansion as
the Queen nicely guards the G for square
from E to b5 we will have a casting on
the opposite side so it's gonna be a
race black will attack on the Queen side
whereas white will attack on the Kings
side
a3 stopping before for the moment and
now rook the b8 preparing before and
this game even though it's a
three-minute blitz game for example ding
Lyra and reach this exact same exact
same position in 2017 in China team
championship
he played Bishop to g2 in this position
which is a bit more precise than the
mover Mac Zulu played as it immediately
goes for the c6 squared the idea is to
push a 5 and put this knight on c6 and
the bishop will will try and protect it
from there
maxilla first went for h4 and this is a
new move in the position so as of move
12 we have a completely new game so this
gives time for black to start the attack
on the Kings side he pushes b4 now White
has to react why it doesn't have time
for for this maneuver anymore we have a
cactus root captures and now Bishop the
g2 so again going for this ePHI plan and
I believe it was sometime somewhere
around this point that Maqsood was said
that he's not really a a knight or
specialist and that he will get punished
for this idea we have Queen to b6 now
with a double attack on the b2 pond and
also on the night here but again this
gives a white chances for some very
interesting ideas and this is a game
worthy of analyzing I mean this position
you could analyze this for a very long
time even in a classical game you have
Bishop captures here your eye you have
ideas like Knight to f5 just offering a
piece after captures captures you have
ideas to the crushed black along the
e-file
if black just castles or leaves the the
bishop unguarded you can just pick pick
it up so it's really just a not even a
piece sacrifice this seems a bit
dangerous but even after rook captures
it the knight guards the b1 square so
it's not gonna be that dangerous but
okay Mac Zulu goes for e5 instead
right away now again c6 is available for
the night so we cannot allow this mock
Zulu grabs the night
sorry alsina grabs the night Luke after
sandy for we have each captures an f6
now winning back the piece and now G
captures an f6 with an attack on the
Bishop Bishop to h6 you could throw in
rook after sandy for instead but mokuba
once I'll see you at the capture so he
can get his h1 rook into the game you
know without losing time so real capture
sandy one with rook after sandy one and
now Bishop the beasts of encountering
White's Bishop and here mokuba said that
he wants to play f5 but he has to decide
whether to trade or not to trade first
he doesn't want to waste a lot of time
but even though it's a three-minute
blitz game max Louise I believe already
a minute up on the clock so he just
grabs it with Queen captures and f5 now
and this is a structure that you will
often face when you're attacking the
knight or so you should know what what
happens and how you should approach the
the pawns because even if you push up on
it doesn't mean that you will able to
open up the structure for example why
black can just play e5 here although
here if I would be would be impossible
to play for black the rook is never you
know coming into the game this Bishop is
a terrible piece you cannot push d5 even
if you prepared White will most likely
be able to stop it
this night is coming to d5 White is just
much better here and black that doesn't
really have any any good options here so
instead we have Knight to e5 but now max
ulu creates another threat g5 and here
there are a lot of ideas captures here
captures here the real threat however is
Bishop to g7 creating a double attack
against the rook and then just grabbing
this f6 bone so I'll Cena captures f
garrison g5 we have F captures on e6 now
forcing black to react we have F
captures on e6 and now comes in Bishop
to g7 and here white black will not be
able to do all that much queen is coming
to h5 if you don't want to give up the
exchange you have to move the rook rook
to g8 displayed but now burst up
captures on e5 you are forced to capture
otherwise you're going to be down a
piece so characters and now as if the
rook is nicely controlling the D file
Queen
age five with check now we have rook to
g6 blocking if you don't block if you
try and run away just rook the f1 check
and there's nothing you can do King here
you can just deliver check in here and
this will be made so after Queen to h5
group to g6 blocking and now Queen
captures on h7 and we have looked to f6
but now the knight comes into the game
with tempo Knight e4 and the knight is
nicely covered by the Queen as you might
have noticed as you know due to the
thumbnail of the video so rook the f4
was played but now feel free to pause
the video and try to find the quickest
way to win this for mark Zulu well I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that the
Queen on b7 is undefended and that the
that there is a nice fork available here
so mocs will just played Knight to d6
check congratulations to everyone who
found it and of course for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show and here
you can just resign because you're
losing the Queen so i'll cena capture
the night but then max will just play
Queen captures on b7 and it was in this
position that Daniel Alsina resigned the
game as he is now down a queen so really
impressive stuff
beautiful attack against the night off
and you know if you plug ins the night
off a lot you will be able to perhaps
use some of this ideas in your own games
so yeah that's what I wanted to show you
like I said I will show you one of them
the games from my tournament there's a
lot of you have requested them later
today I would also like to mention that
today I will be a guest on Ben Johnson's
podcast about chess so if any of you
follow Ben Jonson you know you can enjoy
that as well I will of course provide a
link once the ones the podcast is
uploaded as I don't think he's doing
them live so I will share that we if you
will be interested but yeah that's
pretty much it I would like to thank
Patrick pagoda Vera Bradley johannes de
Rita Jeff graves and William Mackay for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing well that to show
you one of the games I played in the
tournament and yes I'm still preparing
the Morphy saga
so thank y'all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day